In this lesson we're
going to look at optimizers.
Optimizers sound scary, but
they're really cool and really fun.
I'm going to show you all kinds of neat
things you can do with optimizers.
What is an optimizer?
An optimizer is an algorithm that
can do the following things.
Optimizers can be used to find
minimum values for functions.
So say you have a function
like f(x)=x2+x3+5 or
something like that,
an optimizer can find.
For what value of x is this
overall function minimized?
Another thing that optimizers can
do is find the parameters for
parameterized models from data.
So we might have some data
from some experiment, and
we can use optimizers to find
a polynomial fit to that data.
And that is actually one thing we
are going to learn in this lesson.
Finally, we can use an optimizer
to refine allocations to
stocks in portfolios.
What does that mean?
Well, that means for instance,
you can decide what percentage of
funds should be allocated to
each stock using an optimizer.
How do we use an optimizer?
It's really just as simple
as three key steps.
First thing you need to do is define
a function that you want to minimize.
As an example you might
use something like f of x
is equal to x square plus point five.
You define that in Python and then the
minimizer will call this function many,
many times as it tries to
find the minimum values for
x that causes this function
overall to be smallest.
You also need to start
with an initial guess for
x that you think might be close
to the solution to the problem.
If you don't really know,
then you can choose a random value or
just some standard value.
But then the optimizer starts
with that guess and it repeatedly
calls a function, tests different
values, and narrows in on the solution.
Finally, you call the optimizer
with these parameters and
stand back while it searches for
the minimum.